aujourd'hui je vous parlais de votre
maison connectée je ne sais pas si vous
vous intéressez la maison connectée si
c'est votre dada c'est votre truc c'est
de tomber sur conseils je me marre si ça
vous intéresse à nouveau connectés oui
ou non est dommage que ça vachement
intéressant le g bluetec j'ai le plein
de choses et d'objets connectés les
smartphones tout ça et quand on ne parle
de rajouter un objet chez moi qui fais
taper à ma place qui ne solutionne la
vie et qui remonte quotidien plus facile
jolie oui je dit un grand oui
aujourd'hui je vous propose de découvrir
ce produit large pas si vous connaissez
la marque c et kovacs et kovacs fabrique
des produits pour la maison ça c'est un
produit culpa robot aspirateur connectés
c'est la référence à l'est la de boot
aux mots 900 robot qui écoule kg est
juste là on regarde je le transmets
normalement on ne promet pas trop comme
ça celui là mais là alors que tout se
permettre
soyons fous ici et demain soir sans le
faire tomber c'est lui il est très sympa
il est très mignon il fera pas la
vaisselle il frappa le café ils vous
disent pas bonjour il va pas vous
apprendre plein de choses par contre il
va vraiment vous permettre d'économiser
du temps chez vous de passer du temps je
dirais à en faire autre chose que ta et
tâches ménagères
je déteste ça à étages qui la gère je
voulais déjà dit vous ai déjà parlé de
robots aspirateurs et je suis ça
pourrait être cool de parler justement
le sort on voit la vidéo qui est réalisé
en partenariat avec eco max qui permet
justement aujourd'hui de venir tester ce
petit robot regarder on peut même
prendre comme ça alors qu il est cool
il fait plein de choses plein de choses
vraiment intéressantes vous allez voir
vous n'allez pas le regretter
[Musique]
est ce que la question des robots des
robots aspirateurs des robots
domestiques ou en règle générale d'ims
au sens large sont des choses qui vous
intéressent la robotique développe
énormément à céret depuis quelques
années on a vu arriver des robots
aspirateurs qui venait améliorer votre
quotidien et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est vraiment ce que j'aime
avec ce robot là parce que il fait
beaucoup de choses pour vous la première
chose c'est vous pouvez déjà commencer
par le programme média matters tu vas
passer l'aspirateur quel jour à telle
heure qui ne va pas se passer
l'aspirateur la nuit entre tel et tel
créneau parce que je dors parce que je
ne veux pas que tu viennes membres
étaient menacés la fonctionnalité de
base vous allez pouvoir régler le niveau
d'inspiration qu'il aspire shirin
normalement comprend des zones dans
lesquelles il va passer vous puissiez
augmenter la puissance d'aspiration cite
par exemple et pas sur un tapis là où ce
sera plus difficile à aspirer il va le
faire ils vont augmenter la puissance et
ça ira beaucoup plus long donc ça c'est
vachement bien
il va aspirer dans plus de sable il peut
venir laver vous avez qu'à rajouter un
mélange avec d'autres savons ce que vous
voulez et il va passer va vous laisser
une petite traîne derrière lui où il va
venir je dirais nettoyer pas vraiment en
profondeur c'est je dirais un un usage
quotidien
il va venir vraiment de faire un clean
tous les jours ou en tout cas les jours
lequel vous l'aurez programmée rien ne
vous empêche pas ce que voulait faire le
grand ménage de printemps ensuite d'y
aller vous d'astiquer est là pour que ça
brille vraiment mais là c'est vraiment
bien ça dégrossi quotidien que ça
facilite le quotidien et ça prouve
vraiment intéressant que ces solutions
là la première chose intéressante avec
le robot c'est ce que vous allez voir au
niveau des brosses là vous avez deux
brosses rotatives qui vont tourner pour
venir amener les allées les petites
cochonneries ici ici là vous avez ans et
une autre petite brosse et il a tout
l'aspiration se fait par la dsa vous
ramener directement l'intérieur mais si
vous ne voulez pas avoir cette petite
brosse la pop juste mettre une petite
partie des spires à sion 5 qui fournit
intérieur de la boîte comme ça ça veut
juste aspirer et savent aspirer fort en
plus de ça est ce que vraiment génial
avec ce typologie de produits c'est que
vous avez sur le dessus parce qu'il
voyait bien cette petite partie alors ce
n'est pas du tout une soucoupe volante
et un laser compétences qui va faire
c'est qu'il a cartographié votre pièce
votre robot se promènent
il va effectivement grâce à son laser
repérer les objets les obstacles les
murs tout ça tout ça se permettre
d'avoir une connaissance de votre pièce
de savoir où est-ce qu'il peut aller où
f qui doit s'arrêter surtout me faire
une cartographie complète de votre
maison et vous dans votre application
vous allez pouvoir voir grâce à la carte
qui serait en train de dessiner sous vos
yeux
à quel endroit il est passé à quel
endroit il n'est pas passé s'il ya un
objet s'il est passé au tour s'il a
parlé tout est parfaitement incertain
donne vous le verrez vous saurez tout et
ça c'est vraiment génial et c'est
vraiment une belle innovation qu'on
retrouve dans les aspirateurs je dirais
de cette génération là c'est vraiment ce
laser ça vous fait un vrai reporting
centre qui s'est passé quand vous
n'étiez pas là dans ce café l'aspirateur
sur ce qui l'a pas fait et ça c'est gros
point positif est justement une
application qui s'appelle ecomax sommes
alors l'application est intéressante et
pour plusieurs raisons
la première chose c'est qu'effectivement
ce départ programmé les ors laquelle
vous laisse votre aspirateur passe ça
vous pouvez tout gérer directement et
arrière pouvait régler l'intensité vous
pouvez effectivement avoir votre carte
délimiter des zones je veux que tu ne
passe que dans cette zone là par exemple
vous avez renversé de la poussière ou je
sais pas quoi dans un endroit paf vous
délimiter la zone vous l'envoyez il y va
automatiquement il nettoie et est
retourné à la base si vous voulez qu'il
allait nettoyer une pièce en particulier
vous délimiter la zone et il va
également si vous voulez pas qu'ils
aillent dans une zone parce que je sais
le bazar parce qu'à des objets qui
pourraient potentiellement endommager et
bien c'est très simple vous allez vous
mettez des barrières virtuelles et il
n'ira pas et ça c'est vraiment cool
toujours en application vous allez
pouvoir voir le niveau des tas de vos
filtres
si vos fils sont renvoyés tasse il faut
les changer s'il faut les nettoyer en
plus de ça il est compatible google
assistants et amazon avec ça alors ça
dépend des pays ça dépend du pays dans
lequel vous êtes il faut que votre pays
soit compatible vous invite à aller voir
sur le site des kovacs pour voir si
votre pays éligibles est compatible pour
moi aujourd'hui sur un aspirateur comme
ça c'est indispensable d'avoir une
application pour vraiment profiter d'une
expérience je dirais pas en profondeur
mais l'expérience est plus simple pour
l'utilisateur
le fait d'avoir reporting la
programmation soit tout ça vous gérez et
vous voyez ce qui se passe où vous soyez
à l'intérieur des évidemment je voulais
montrer ici vous allez pouvoir rajouter
de l'eau pour la partie nettoyage alors
qu'on nettoyez-vous nez
c'est cette petite partie claque ça vélo
qui va arriver dans sa va nettoyer
c'est vraiment cool mais en plus de ça
et ce qui est génial c'est vous pouvez
régler effectivement jeudi le débit
d'eau qui va être envoyée
et ça c'est vraiment bien en fonction je
dirais de nettoyage que vous allez
vouloir faire si c'est juste un petit
coup d'oeil star du clean enlever les
poussières supérieur ou si vous voulez
envoyer un peu plus de flotte pour venir
nettoyer un peu plus en profondeur
vous allez pouvoir régler ici je peux si
vous le voyez une petite zone qui va
venir pour reconnaître les obstacles
en gros ils avancent étape dans un mur
paf qui reconnaît il des cas lire avant
certains pères connaît il avance et ce
qui est bien c'est qu'effectivement et
bien il ya déjà le laser peut permettre
de voir s'il ya un mur il va avancer il
est en contact ça va venir enclenché
offre idées qu'à la passion de côté et
ça lui évitera effectivement devenir
défoncée ça s'est vraiment bien c'est
très précis ça marche bien on pourrait
se dire comme il héros n'est pas évident
de faire les coins et bien détrompez
vous il va arriver il va toucher les
bases décalé va se décaler et comme vous
avez des petites brosses rotatives la
regarde et qui dépasse sur le côté eh
bien il marche vachement bien
il vous fait les coins ça c'est pratique
et en plus comme il est tout petit ce
qui est pratique c'est qu'il passe sous
les meubles
ça dépend de la hauteur des meubles il
va passer partout mais sous un canapé
bien fonction de la route à blesle
évidemment il faut de plus il pourra
passer potentiellement souffle qui est
aussi potentiellement ceux des meubles
pour venir nettoyer et c'est vraiment
très pratique et si j'allais chez vous
vous avez de vide des escaliers soyez
tranquille n'est pas de souci va pouvoir
détecter
lorsque vous allez avoir du vide grâce à
ses capteurs il ya plein de capteurs
embarqués
c'est qu'il n'a pas à se jeter je vous
le dirai pas à dieu merci pour ce bon
travail il va aller vite et il va
repartir ça c'est aussi pareil
un point qui est relativement rassurants
et quand on achète un robot aspirateur
ce qu'on veut en priorité cette histoire
silencieux on veut pas avoir une turbine
qui tourne chez vous et c'est vrai
qu'aussi il est assez silencieux alors
on va forcément longtemps d'un ça tourne
ça aspire
il bouge on l'entend mais ça reste quand
même relativement s'ils ont su ça c'est
aussi en quoi qui pour moi est vraiment
important sur ce type de produits
maintenant la grosse question c'est
l'autonomie
lorsque vous avez votre robot vous
voulez pas qu'ils passent l'aspirateur
et que bout de dix minutes un quart
d'heure vingt minutes et il se recharge
et parce qu'il soit complètement à plat
là vous êtes plutôt tranquille ça dépend
évidemment de la taille de votre maison
si vous avez une maison qui fait ça sans
avec quatre petits peuvent oublier mais
si vous avez un appât contre 50 m 100 m
150 m² en une seule charge ça devrait le
faire si toutefois ça le fait pas il ira
ensuite se recharger et il retournera
ensuite faire le taf l'autonomie on est
un peu plus d'une heure on est vers 1h20
1h30 bien évidemment et c'est ce qui est
vraiment génial c'est comme vous avez un
reporting vous pouvez voir quelle zone
il aspirait quelle zone il n'a pas
inspiré pour pouvoir si besoin
lorrie norrington spécifique si elles
sont cools votre avec ce produit en tout
cas avec cette typologie de fronde est
parce qu il existe toute une famille il
ya plein de produits hachés cobac de
mitel et jeter un petit coup d'oeil
d'ailleurs vous avez un lien en bas dans
la description c'est que on se
réapproprie le besoin peu différemment
on va plus endettée au délègue des
tâches et c'est ce que je trouve génial
avec la robotique alors savez quand on
n'est qu'au début la robotique l'aller
on arrive à accepter les petits
aspirateur robot la maison parce que
c'est vraiment une tâche ingrate à moins
que vous soyez vraiment quelqu'un qui
ait beaucoup faire mes nageurs vite le
mans aura puis expliquez moi pourquoi
vous aimez moi je ne comprends pas je
déteste absolument faire ménage mais à
côté de ça j'ai déjà dit je le redis une
fois de plus jeudi
vivre dans un environnement sale du coup
il ya des solutions comme ça qu'ils sont
vraiment génial il est très facile à
utiliser
vous avez un petit bouton pour venir à
l'allumer pour l'éteindre à l'intérieur
vous allez retrouver ici un hold up vous
le décalé tac tac ça marche un petit
bouton pour le rct à côté vous avez
votre bac qui se trouve juste là alors
le bac est pas énorme donc à chaque fois
que vous l'avez utilisé je conseille
vraiment devenir le vide et sinon arrivé
à un moment si vous l'avez même
programme et il va plus aspirer
simplement parce que ça ne sera plus
rien passer petit bac tout c'est pas
grave comme vous allez le faire
régulièrement à bien y aura pas trop de
poussière donc ça sera vraiment cool la
spli en lui-même est simple sympa
discret robuste millions voilà moi je
trouve vraiment intéressant je vous
recommande si toutefois vous ne voulez
pas vous embêter si vous voulez
solutionner la question du ménage qui
est vraiment horrible je la déteste ce
robot est cool personnellement ça fait
déjà une bonne année à la maison que
j'allais opérateurs connectés esprit
vous assurer que ça change
franchement le quotidien vous posez lui
la question de dire je suis en vie
qu'elle je vais aller me prendre allez
une heure pour aller passer l'aspirateur
face à coup de serpillière niet
de temps en temps vous le faites quand
même parce qu'il ya toujours des petites
pièces que vous n'arrivez pas à voir des
petits résidus qui traîne mais dès lors
que vous avez programmé une aspiration
régulière tous les jours vous passer un
petit coup d'aspirateur et tous les 2
jours vous prévoyez avec un petit bac 1
pour venir enlever la poussière en
surface ça va garder notre maison dans
un état propre et puis je dirais une
fois par mois vous allez passer avec un
bal un peu plus haut pour aller voir
dans les endroits qui n'ont pas été fait
parce que comme je le dis il ne passe
pas partout ça dépend des mêmes mais
malgré tout c'est vraiment génial je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous ces
aspirateurs robots est ce que vous en
avez un est ce que vous pourriez en
achetant et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
celui et kovacs de boot osmo 900 moi je
trouve cool et si vous intéresse vous
aviez un lien en bas dans la description
sur sonic master vous intéresse
comprendre comme ça de solutions pour la
maison connectée sur le respirateur soit
des enceintes soient pleins de choses
vous marrer tous en bas comme ça je
verrai et puis en potentiellement je
pourrais parler d'autres produits et
puis d'ici là le temps de vous lire est
tous appelés gros bisous prenez soin
visage